Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie!
Thank you, everybody that left questions
on my Game of Thrones video this weekend.
Everybody likes hearing about the Tyrells,
and I did try to include a couple questions
about the Knight of Flowers.
Everyone is still kind of thinking about what's going on
as of the end of season five.
And, don't forget: this weekend actually
Khaleesi Terminator is on the big screen.
Lots of things happening with
Game of Thrones people in the next two weeks.
So I also have Comic-Con news at
the end of this, so here we go.
Just careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up on season five.
So here we go. John Shark asks: "Do you think
that Tormund will lead the Wildlings
against the mutinied crows
as well as the white walkers?
I hope Tormund kills Alliser Thorne this time."
Yeah, I don't think that they're just going
to be sitting around for all of season six.
They're down in the Gift right now.
Remember, that was part of the promise that Jon Snow
made to them - that they would get the Gift
in exchange for coming down.
The Wildlings themselves aren't like super best friends
with Jon Snow or anything like that,
but the Night's Watch hates the Wildlings -
the ones that mutinied.
That was the whole reason for them
killing Jon Snow.  So there's like a 99% chance that
there's going to be something going
on between the Crows and the Wildlings.
The real question is: Are they going to be able
to find some sort of common ground?
Because if the white walkers come,
and they're still fighting each other,
then it's going to be really bad for everyone.
Next question: Akash asks,
"I'm currently reading Dance of Dragons,
and I just read the first Melisandre POV chapter,
and in the vision instead of seeing Stannis
like she wants to, she says 'I ask him to
show me Azor Ahai and all he shows me is snow.'
Do you think that this is hinting that
Jon is going to be Azor Ahai?"
No, not necessarily.  I think that it just indicates that
he is a person of interest to the Lord of Light.
They did a good job at the end of season five
in telling us that Melisandre
isn't always 100% on her game.
She was so confident that Stannis
was going to be the champion of the Red God,
but in the last episode, you see that
look of horror on her face as the blood drains out,
like she's realizing, "Oh my god, I was
wrong about this."  So don't ever take
Melisandre's visions as being super literal.
All I think it means is that
he is a very important character.
It doesn't mean whether he's
important bad or important good.
There's a lot of competing theories that he could be
co-opted by the Night's King and the white walkers,
or he could be co-opted by Melisandre
and the Red God.  Right now,
everything is still widely open to interpretation.
So, if you have a theory that involves Jon Snow
being important, it's at least a little bit right,
no matter what you think.
Next question: Wyatt asks,
"What will happen to the Stormlands,
now that House Baratheon is essentially dead?"
Well, the Crown would probably
just appoint someone else caretaker,
like they would give it to someone else.
And when I say the Crown,
I'm really talking about Kevan Lannister,
because he's the one calling the shots
in the small council right now.
He came back to Kings Landing when
Cersei got her ass thrown in jail,
so he is like the new Tywin in
Kings Landing, although he is no Tywin.
Just in terms of personalities,
I think they're cut from the same cloth,
but Kevan is a little bit softer than Tywin.
He's not quite as hard-core.
Here's a crazy thought: he's not first in line,
but remember Jamie promised Bronn a bigger castle -
a much bigger castle - if he came down
and rescued Myrcella with him?
It looks like Myrcella's dead, but you know
if some other big need were to arise,
the Crown could promise Storm's End to Bronn.
The other Lords would probably get
super pissed about it.
Like, I don't think anybody in the small council,
any of the other aristocracy in Westeros
would go for it.  They'd be super pissed,
because Storm's End is huge.
But it's always possible they could
offer that as a reward to Bronn for
doing something else really really crazy.
Like, "Bring me the head of Tyrion Lannister,
and I will give you Storm's End."
Realistically speaking, though, the Crown
will probably just appoint a temporary caretaker.
Next question: Tac asks, "Will there be
an Aegon's Conquest spinoff series,
or any spinoffs in Game of Thrones?"
Well, I think HBO's going to try and do
everything it can to keep Game of Thrones
on HBO beyond the main series.
So I would say yes to spin-off,
but it's up in the air as to what it could be.
Aegon's conquest would definitely be very interesting,
but I think HBO would go with something
a little bit more familiar.
Typically, when networks do spinoffs,
they use familiar characters.
And like the closest thing we have to characters
that we haven't seen but that we've heard about
on the show are people from Robert's Rebellion
like Lyanna Stark / Rhaegar Targaryen.
If HBO wanted to lay the safest possible bed for a
spinoff series, that's probably what they would do.
If they wanted to get really high concept with it,
then they would do something from the distant past,
like Dunk and Egg or Aegon's Conquest
or even ancient Valyria.
That would probably involve a lot of CG dragons.
Anything requiring heavy special-effects is probably
pretty low on their list.
Robert's Rebellion would look
almost exactly like Game of Thrones
does right now, and I think HBO likes that idea.
It just means they wouldn't have to pay tens of
millions of dollars for really different costumes,
really different locations; they could shoot a lot of
the same places and just redress them a little bit.
Plus you have the added action
of a major conflict, like a major sh-t storm,
and those tend to be very exciting to
watch on-screen.
The problem is that if they did something more
with Game of Thrones, they would probably still want to
maintain some of the really amazing WTF stuff like
white walkers, and we just we didn't see a whole lot
of white walkers during Robert's Rebellion;
they had just started to resurface at the end of that.
So there are going to be issues no matter
what they choose but I think, you know,
Robert's Rebellion is the safe bet,
but something cooler would be Dunk and Egg.
Next question: Medelean asks, "Who do you think
can restore peace and control in the North,
now that Stannis is dead and the Starks are lost?"
Well, I think the Boltons are really in charge
of keeping the North under control,
although Littlefinger is trying to move in on that.
Littlefinger doesn't strike me as the type
to bring peace, so I think for most of season six,
Roose Bolton is going to try and do it, but
"The North Will Remember" in super hard-core ways.
Like, seriously, they're casting
a bunch of people for Northern storylines.
So, if anything, season six up in the North
is going to look a lot more like it did
during the War of the Five Kings.
The North making war against Roose Bolton
and thinning out his ranks.
His army is still pretty big; like, whenever
he fought Stannis at the end of the season,
it looked like he had a massive army.
So maybe the North will be culling that
through the course of season six.
Next question: SJ Burks asks,
"Can you talk about the differences between
the Knight of Flowers on the show versus the books?"
Well, you're talking about Loras.
He's called the Knight of Flowers because of
his personal coat of arms.  It's just a variation on
the traditional House Tyrell coat of arms.
He has three golden flowers
on a field of green.
It's just meant to honor his own personal taste
and his position as third son.
Really, the biggest change, and it's actually
a pretty big one, is that in the books
Loras is part of Joffrey's Kingsguard.
He spends a lot more time and proximity to Jamie,
so Jamie thinks about him in his POV chapters.
On the show, you really don't get a sense for
his character as much as you do in the books.
Jamie thinks of him as "not being false", meaning
like he's not a complete liar but he hasn't proven himself
as a true knight yet.  But for the most part,
the show has hit a lot of like the really big stuff.
He was part of Renly's Rainbow Knights
during the War of the Five Kings,
but what the show has done is try to
marry him to Cersei,
so that that's why he's not in the Kingsguard,
because Kingsguard can't marry.
And even before he was supposed to marry Cersei
he was supposed to marry Sansa,
so he couldn't be in the Kingsguard then either.
So, I think that's why the show made that change.
Next question: Mercury Wolff
asks, "Why are the Lannisters so evil? Why do they
believe themselves better than anyone else?"
Well, I mean, that's a matter of perspective.
I wouldn't call them evil; I would just say
most of them are very determined.
Cersei is the closest thing you could call
to being a cruel Lannister.
And when you think about it from Cersei's perspective,
I mean the show doesn't do POV chapters,
so you don't get a sense for this, but in the books,
Cersei just feels very undermined.
Like, she feels growing up a woman there were
a lot of opportunities that weren't given to her
just because Westeros is such a patriarchy.
She even jokes that as children,
because Jamie and Cersei were twins,
they would actually switch clothes; Jamie would
dress up in her little girl's clothing and
she would dress up in his armor, and they would
walk around the castle to see if anybody noticed,
and usually nobody would notice.
So, she thinks to herself, you know,
"Had I grown up a man, I wouldn't be having
all these problems that I'm having right now."
We have no idea what would happen had
she actually been born a man,
but if you really look at it,
she kind of is the son that Tywin always wanted:
she wants power.
The problem is that her circumstances
have led her to make some very
questionable choices this past season,
so I think you could argue either way, you know,
like, even if she had been born a man,
maybe she'd still be just as nuts as she is right now.
So, the Lannisters aren't so much evil
as they are morally gray.
The closest thing to an evil person
on the show, you know, just in terms of
the great houses right now,
would be Roose Bolton.
Just rewatch that scene where he tells Ramsey about
his mother, and tell me that Roose Bolton is not evil.
Next question: Eun-Bi asks, "Is Danaerys going to
free her other dragons someday?"
Well, I would say,
"While mother's away, the dragons will play."
So, you know, while Tyrion is watching Meereen,
don't expect everything to go completely smoothly
with the dragons.
Somebody still has to feed them while she's gone.
I don't know whether or not they'll get out or how soon,
but I think that they're just a bomb waiting to go off.
They're kind of like the Wildlings sitting down in the Gift;
they're not just going to sit around
for an entire season and do nothing.
We can only hope that they'll just make
some really spectacular mess and it will be
amazing to watch on-screen next question Asks
what's can happen to Mace Tyrell and Braavos
is he going to die there what you know I think
you know if you're talking about the stuff
going on with Aaria I think the whole reason
for all that problem stuff with Mace was really
to get Meryn Trant there like that's that's
why the writers wrote it that way they resolved
that storyline in the season finale Meryn
Trant is gone so think Mace Tyrell is just
going to come back and he'll just be back
in Kings Landing during season six Kevan Lannister
looks like he's fixed the small counsel and
they need their master of coin and that's
what Mace Tyrell is so they need him back
in Kings Landing next question Matalin asks
where's Dolores Ed we know he survived Hardhome
in the boat with Jon why was that he with
Jon at the season finale Willie I mean it
was like the end of the night so he was probably
asleep the address that in episode one yet
remember the ended on a cliffhanger so they
have to tell us what happens in the moments
after that someone has to find his body everyone
has to go nuts because those people they killed
Jon that wasn't the entire Knights watch that
was really on the back half of them so don't
worry will find out what Dolores Ed is going
to do will find out where ghost is like he'll
probably show up again Cersei that's an even
bigger question where was ghost in the season
finale what was he doing he was probably off
hunting but if Drogon can sense the Daenerys
is in trouble and come to her aid then why
didn't ghost do that he must've just found
like the biggest tastiest rabbit ever next
question Jon asks how the hell is she going
to face the white walkers without Dragonglass
she screwed what defense do white walkers
have against dragons what sounds like you
kinda answered your own question little bit
she has Dragon so she doesn't need Dragonglass
is much as for white walkers fighting dragons
I would think that they would just use projectiles
they have a special spears made of enchanted
ice so they would the probably just find a
way to use is is projectiles against dragons
there were flying around just like white walkers
would be week against dragons dragons would
be week against white walkers one of the really
good things about game of thrones is that
no one is like supremely overpowered even
though it seems like Daenerys is overpowered
with her dragons the workaround to that is
is the dragons just can be completely controlled
it's like raising a lien you can teach it
to do tricks but it still might end up biting
you because it's instinct is genetic like
it will always be stronger than what you program
it to do so thank you so much everyone for
so many questions are always a ton of fun
to do what's can happen next is all post by
Arthur Dayne video and then I'll do a, con
preview after that just kind of explaining
was going to be going on with the game of
thrones panel what my schedule is going to
be like the of the videos I'll be doing that
week really I just want to couch your expectations
for that game of thrones panel they don't
really give any good information away about
the next season the usually show blooper reel
and a casting video but because, con is so
early this year is totally possible that they
won't have that casting video it be a big
disappointment so I'm hoping they bring it
Maisie Williams did tease the faceless men
last year but we kinda knew that was going
to happen already so wasn't a big revelation
you can even consider it spoilery for those
asking about meet ups there will be a, con
meet up I just I don't know exactly when it's
going to be I'm still finalizing my schedule
he'll probably be sometime Friday or Saturday
so that will be some point during the weekend
when you can come you know give me hi5 in
and say hello which is reminds me congratulations
to this week's giveaway winter Nuveen Kumar
you when a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on my channel so I get
your contact info if you just since the I
posted a guardians video yesterday I meant
to start a new Marvel giveaway in that so
if you want to enter the Marvel giveaway for
this week just go leave a comment on that
guardians video you can click here for that
and you can click here to learn all about
resurrection in a song of ice and fire thank
you so much for watching, everybody let's
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!